[Musique]
son tour de la manne c'est surtout le
ballon et fonce metal et petit canard
et pour que tout le monde se marre au vu
des bons votre enfant présente acquis du
bec
avec beaucoup d'entrain nick white
points à limete au recoux on s'amuse
comme de qui faut maintenant oublier les
jours
[Musique]
mais j
c'est super chouette c'est extra c'est
la danse des canards les gamins comme
les loups pas bon dans ccb refram dans
tous les coins
ne soyez pas en retard car la danse des
canards c'est le tube de queen
il suffit de fermer son big en
maintenance et plymouth est dit et les
génisses et bien il fait le point
ça y est vous avez compris attention
c'est pas fini nous avons jusqu'au matin
vers des quadras
[Musique]
le haut
mais j
ouais
te c'est super chouette cette extraction
il
c'est la danse des canards puis en
sortant de la marge sur tout le bas des
reins et font des pincettes comme le
petit canard
et pour que tout le monde se met à fumer
des combats intenses eu des canaris en
sortant de la main on se souhaite ou le
bas des reins c'est à l'émeute et
surtout on s'amuse comme des petits fous
maintenant plier les genoux grasset
[Musique]
fin
bah
bgi
c'est super chouette c'est extra c'est
la danse des canards qui en sautant de
la main sur tout le bas des reins et
font craindre un fait comme les petits
canards et pour que tout le monde se
marre de pays pauvres
c'est la danse des canards les gamins
tomber nous parlons dans ces seguin
printemps tous les coins ne soyez pas en
retard
la danse des canards c'est le tube
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]